So I often get asked if there's a person or
company out there that I find inspiring
who I think is out there helping others and
work in a unique and special way.
And the answer is,
of course, of course, of course.
One of my favorite examples is Spanx,
founded by Sara Blakely.
Sara's completely reinventing how business
works.
She's bringing this balanced feminine energy
into business,
things like caring, empathy, patience.
But what I love about what Sara is doing for
her people,
is she treats everyone like an entrepreneur.
Entrepreneurs generally start business
and know nothing about what they're doing and
have to figure it out along the way.
Sara tells all of her employees:
pretend you're an entrepreneur and
pretend you have no idea how to do this job
and you have to figure it out
along the way.
And what ends up happening is the people in
her company are finding
new ways to do old jobs better
because they're treating it as
if it's an entrepreneurial venture.
Like there are no rules here,
that I can figure out how to get this job done
in a way that I think is new and better,
instead of worrying about
have I learned the right things.
And Spanx has been a hugely inspiring company
both internally and externally.
And I love learning from Sara and from all
the things that she's doing.
So Spanx is is a great example of a company
doing things differently.